joy on youtube as well i'll be sharing
the link with you all
hi pradeep
if any one of you has any question in
the middle of the session you can
then and they'll put it in the chat box
and our team would be there to
answer your question
i hope everyone has joined and now let's
begin with the webinar
while others can join in the midst of it
as well
so a very warm welcome everyone thank
you for joining today's session
and i would like to welcome you all for
this today's webinar on the overview of
omixlogic genomics in the virtual lab
today we would start with the
introduction to the omixlogic training
and platforms
and then we would hear from our experts
about genomics
and future medicine
followed by a video presentation by our
program mentor dr
sona vasudevan and then we will go
through the schedule of the entire
program and go through the upcoming
opportunities
as well so before we start with the talk
i would want to introduce us
we are a us-based bioinformatics company
who is working with multiple academic
and commercial collaborators to develop
easy to
use analytical tools and our mission is
to make bioinformatics more accessible
omixlogic is an international program
that is running in five different
regions with over 10 000 users around
the world
and due to this fast growth our team is
working with local and regional
coordinators that
are helping refine local program
logistics
and leverage our online training
resources adapting them to the needs of
the students and
researchers around the world omixlogic
research-based training programs are a
result of close collaboration between
pine biotech
and numerous academic institutions that
have participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
my name is sunalika ray and i am the
omixlogic community manager responsible
for daily interaction with thousands of
users that are a part of a
bioinformatics community
managed by pine biotech now coming back
to the program
genomics in the virtual lab is a special
opportunity to learn
about genomics and big data analysis
from world-renowned scientists and a
team of bioinformaticians
working on cutting-edge big data
challenges in biomedical
research in this online program
participants will learn about the
analysis of high throughput genomics
data
and would apply complex and
computationally intensive data
processing steps
to large-scale public domain data
now let me introduce our program mentors
and guest speaker
we have dr harpreet with us she has an
expertise in the application of
statistical machine learning techniques
on biomedical data
and the development of prediction tools
and databases
and she looks after the curriculum
development bioinformatics and data
science course development
then we have dr mohit mazumdar he is an
experienced bioinformatician with
multiple publications
in peer review journals and
collaborations in industry and academia
and over the past several years he has
been developing collaborations with
universities
as a mentor and project lead for omix
logic training and research fellowship
elia broski is the ceo of pine biotech
and then we have our program mentor she
is dr
sona vasudevan professor of biochemistry
and molecular biology at
georgetown university medical college
she would be mentoring our students and
would present disease associated
projects that our
participants can learn from and
ultimately see how genomics
is used at the intersection of data
science and biomedicine
dr arigi research associate professor
center of bioinformatics and
computational biology
department of computer information
sciences university of delaware
would be our guest speaker for the
program dr
araghi leaves the uniprod database
efforts
and leads the biocreative and
biocuration efforts as well
now i would like to pass it on to india
who will be
the co-mentor of the program over to you
ilya
thank you very much i'm going to share
my screen
okay so welcome everyone to this webinar
it's exciting to see all of you here
today
and uh what i will try to do in my part
of the presentation is to briefly tell
you about
the reason why this program is the right
place
for you to start as you're learning
about genomics
so first of all let me briefly introduce
myself
i have been working with pine biotech
for several years now and
i have been a part of many different
presentations and training sessions that
were related to bioinformatics
for a variety of different levels
starting from
faculty and graduate students but also
including high school students so
we have built a team of academic
advisors and collaborators as well as
facilitators that will include
many different uh types of people that
can help you along the way
and what we have really been focused on
is how we
can use our expertise and the network
that we have
to bring to you the best possible
experience learning about bioinformatics
in a virtual setting so how do we take
what we have successfully done
offline and bring it online in a way
that all of you could participate
and get an equally excellent experience
learning about
applications of big data to a variety of
biomedical challenges
but also how to work on translational
research
challenges that are relevant to where
you are right now
so let me start by kind of telling you
why bioinformatics and genomics is such
a relevant topic today
so from the 1950s after the dna double
helix structure was discovered
right away there was a focus on trying
to understand
what is encoded in the dna and so as a
result
of the human genome project and that led
to many other
species being sequenced we started to
really
accumulate a huge volume of data
and that volume of data today is
accessible to
anyone that has access to the internet
now what's interesting about this is
that this data
actually comes with a lot of variation
and so the topic of genomics the study
of genomics
is really focused on looking at the dna
code trying to find patterns
and bugs in the code that might lead to
phenotypic changes
or changes in the actual functional
molecules that our cells use to operate
and function as we grow and so these
bugs in the code
could result in major changes that are
associated
with a few different important
biomedical challenges and these include
drug metabolism so for example
the function of different enzymes that
process the drugs that
are prescribed to patients and that
could result
in patients being non-responsive to
treatment
or maybe even having a toxic
reaction to a treatment that has to do
with cancer so a lot of cancers are
associated
with what's called somatic mutations
mutations that
accumulate as the cells divide and as
they accumulate
that might disrupt some of the
regulatory networks that control
different properties of cells and make
them into what they are causing tumors
to grow
and causing them to spread or
metastasize
that has to do with inherited diseases
and those inherited diseases could be a
result of
many different environmental factors
over a long period of time
as well as rare genetic diseases and so
those rare genetic diseases
uh could be something that
essentially uh endangers the person
at a certain time uh or prevents them
from
uh developing certain important
functions
as they grow and so all of this is
linked to a variety of different types
of genomic information that we could
acquire
and what's interesting is that as
opposed to just maybe a few years ago
this is now in the clinic so genomic
medicine
and the application of genomics in
treating patients
interacting with patients today is not
just
something that we talk about happening
in the future this is happening right
now
and it starts from collecting
information
that would help us interpret the found
genomic mutations
in a patient sample so that that could
be
incorporated into the treatment plan
so today this is already being used
there are many different
genetic tests for history
for different kind of predisposition of
risk but also for treatment and for
accurate diagnostics
as i mentioned in cancer this is a very
critical component of cancer care
including the identification of
early stage signatures that could help
us
treat cancer better so as you know
cancer is a
huge challenge around the world in many
different parts of the world there are
different types of cancers
liver cancer breast cancer lung cancer
they kill
millions of people every year and what
is a
critical step in being able to address
cancer better
is early detection so the earlier we can
identify
a cancer developing in some cells
the earlier they could be treated
another important part is
accurate and personalized treatment and
so that has to do with genomic
information as well
as you all know a good example of that
is the p53 gene this is a gene that is
typically found in many of the tumors
in many different types of cancers and
there
just a small number of mutations can
cause that gene
to stop functioning the protein that is
in coding
will stop functioning properly and
essentially will lead to
unproliferated growth and uncontrollable
uncontrollable tumor
development so this is an example in
cancer
as you know as i mentioned there are
other types of
genomic information associated with
disease for example
cystic fibrosis and to really appreciate
the diversity of information that
genomic data provides
it really could be applied in so many
different cases
and there's a complex way to kind of
categorize these types of mutations to
really understand
what is their impact and so you can see
that
here we can see a number of different
types of mutations that are affecting
the protein synthesis the maturation and
processing
ion channel gating and others and so
when we look at the data that is
generated
about the genome we really need to know
how to analyze this data looking at
single point mutations and also
sometimes looking at
whole regions that are being changed and
so as a result
when we speak about genomic data and the
variety of different
use cases we can apply genomic
surveillance
genomic analysis for variant calling
as well as unsupervised analysis of
genomic data
ultimately to find associations between
the genomic variants and the phenotype
this phenotype could be disease as it
is caused by what's happening in the
human dna the host dna in the patients
or it could be caused by pathogens and
so another whole
important area of our application for
genomic data
is the study of genomics from
pathogens from viruses bacteria and from
parasites and so tuberculosis is one of
those examples
as we know there is a huge problem with
drug resistant bacteria that is now not
responding to
a single type of antibiotic or
what's called a multi-drug resistant
bacteria as well
and those could be detected by analyzing
publicly available genomic data
so another example for this kind of
application is the ebola virus as we
know in the 2014
to 2016 the outbreak of ebola in west
africa
caused the whole world to be concerned
about ebola spreading around the world
and causing a pandemic
but thankfully because so much effort
has been put into
addressing this problem early on the
understanding of what causes
the mutations that are being acquired in
this new type of ebola strain were
identified
it was identified what is the critical
protein
and a vaccine could be designed very
quickly
and so that was a combination of factors
on one hand genomic data availability
and the efforts of researchers around
the world
on another hand it's the understanding
about the relationship between sequence
and structure which is a very important
part
of what we will be talking about in this
program
so one side it's the genomic data as you
can see
right here on the right on the other
side it's the proteins that are being
encoded by these specific genes
and how do these mutations actually fit
into that picture
and how we can utilize that so as i
mentioned
at the foundation here we have
the sequencing technologies that have
over the years
diversified providing us with a variety
of different types of sequence
information
and to understand how to process this
data
we have to understand how to analyze
this data properly
and so that's why in this program we'll
talk a little bit about
the history of genomic data sequencing
how to
analyze and identify specific mutations
how to categorize these mutations and so
there's a lot of
uh individual types of mutations that we
could think about
but we will try to go through all of the
different
types and terminology so that all of you
are prepared
to look at genomic data and actually
find associations with a phenotype
that you could link because you
understand the data and so that brings
me to
this field of bioinformatics so
ultimately
what we talked about up until now is
the application of genomics in a variety
of fields
primarily in biomedicine but at the
core of being able to perform such
projects and learn from this data
lies this bioinformatics
discipline and the bioinformatics
discipline combines
the understanding of biological
challenges or
biomedical challenges that we just heard
about
with two important aspects informatics
and statistics and so informatics has to
do with
information technologies and data
management how to find data
how to download data how to annotate
this data
how to store this data in in certain
formats
and then statistics how do we analyze
the
amount of data that we have to get some
meaningful information out of it
so that we can do inference so that we
can infer from this data
associations with meaningful patterns
that we know about
the patients that we are studying and so
the
intersection of these three fields
informatics statistics and biology
is actually the definition of
bioinformatics
and so to talk about bioinformatics and
to help people
acquire skills in bioinformatics i want
to introduce you today
to the omics logic portal and some
important
things that you can gain from this
portal as we
speak about genomics in the virtual lab
the program that i will show you
in just a brief moment so
uh when we uh if you could please
go with me to omix logic the portal
so maybe somebody
can share the link
okay
so the link is learn.omexlogic.com
thank you sonalika please go to this
portal
and uh if you could please
register on this portal this is free
registration
and anyone who is participating in the
program or who would like to participate
in the program
uh would be leveraging some of the
resources we have on the portal
to be able to go through the session so
i will give you just a couple of minutes
if you could please register on this
portal the registration is free
and then we will speak about the topics
and the process for actual registration
to the program
okay so once you register please put
number one
or yes in the chat so i know that you're
already registered
okay thank you
i'll just give it a couple more minutes
so all of you that are registering as
you register
please let us know in the chat
and then i'll be able to show you a few
more things so that everyone
will be able to appreciate what kind of
resources are going to be available
for you in this program
all right great thank you i see a few of
you are registering right now
okay so once you have registered uh
you can go ahead and navigate to this
tab called
courses and i'll just give you a few
examples
of what has been made available through
this portal
and how it fits in with what we're going
to be doing
okay so once you're on the courses tab
you can go ahead and navigate right here
if you're in the search tab to a
course called bytes and molecules now
this is a free course
anyone can take it and this will help
you establish
some of the terminology and the basic
concepts
behind genomic data analysis it will
talk about
why we should study genomics how we
should study genomics
and what are some of the exciting
examples of the application of genomics
in a variety of fields
so you can learn about this by
completing this course
another course that i would recommend
for all of you that are joining today is
a course
called introduction to bioinformatics
so the first course will give you the
general background and the terminology
and will refresh your molecular biology
con
concept so that you understand how all
of this works together
introduction to bioinformatics will
introduce you to the challenges and
opportunities
with big data such as next generation
sequencing
and how this data could be analyzed and
it will go on
into a more detailed description of the
applications of
bioinformatics in the field of
biomedical research
clinical applications pharmaceutical
drug discovery
as well as biotechnology and agriculture
so i highly recommend for all of you
that are interested to join the program
to start looking at this coursework it's
very accessible
it's free and you can use this right
away
to prepare for the program that we're
going to be starting
now to talk about the program we can go
on the main menu right here to the
programs tab
and on here you will find a variety of
different
training programs that are not
asynchronous they're not online courses
they are guided
by a mentor and so this program called
genomics in the virtual lab is going to
be found right here
and in this program this is going to be
a special opportunity because it is
going to be guided by someone who has
years of experience working in
application of bioinformatics to
biomedicine
but also a program director that
is very passionate about education and
so
instead of teaching her master's degree
program
over the summer she is actually going to
be spending her time working with
students
and beginners to give them the
opportunity to
appreciate bioinformatics and genomics
in the context of biomedical research
so i think this is a very exciting
opportunity
she has years of experience working for
nih working at georgetown university
medical
school where she is participating in
many different exciting research
projects
but also she is a director of a program
called systems medicine
and really a leader in the field of
systems medicine
where they speak about the need to
integrate
data including genomic data to be able
to offer
better treatments uh to patients with a
variety of different uh
diseases so to understand what the
program is going to be like
i think he we here have a video of a
group project that the previous
participants put together
you can scroll down and see some
information about
the schedule and the important thing is
that the
time for the program is going to start
from the
21st so on monday we will have our first
session
and it will go on for two weeks and
during those two weeks you'll be able to
learn
what you need to know to get started
with genomic data analysis
but in the later part of this session
we'll talk
about some of the other outcomes for
this program as well
so before um we continue we want to
mention uh what the program is going to
be like and so i think we have
uh dr sona vasudevan from georgetown
university
who's going to speak a little bit about
the history
of bioinformatics and how it relates to
georgetown university
really the school that she represents so
you can hear a little bit about the
connection
between bioinformatics and genomics
for um thank you okay go ahead
now there are lots of sub-disciplines
within bioinformatics because
bioinformatics is an
interdisciplinary field because we need
computer scientists we need biologists
we need even economic economists right
now right
so we need it's an interdisciplinary
feat so there is a development of new
algorithms and
you have statistics because the minute
you talk about big data
you need statistics because you want to
see if this one
single mutation is actually
statistically
significant for us to say yes this
particular mutation causes that
particular disease
right and then we have an analysis and
interpretation of various types of data
including nucleotides amino acid
sequences protein domains and protein
structures
and how do we get structures to function
and all of those things and then the
development and implementation of tools
because we can have we can generate data
we can have computer scientists to
develop tools
to look at the data and we also need
without tools we cannot even mine and
look at this data that's what this
course you're going to be learning about
a lot of resources where there is data
but also you're going to be using tools
to be able to
use how do you use the data without
tools right but
we are going to be focusing just on this
aspect of
nucleotides and acid structures and all
of that for the first one
right now is informatics a new field
what do you think i really love to ask
this question to all my students and i
get different kinds of answers
so i would like to know of course i wish
i had some polling
uh set up so that we could have just
pulled now
what do you all think is bioinformatics
a new field
or not you can just type s or no answer
into the chat and we'll see
we'll just wait for a second and see
okay no bioinformatics is not a
or is not a new field okay i'm seeing a
lot of near no no no no no that is
actually
no okay so bioinformatics is
actually you're right it's not a new
field right
so um where do you think it was born so
bioinformatics is not a new field
um but where was bioinformatics actually
born who gave
to this whole field of bioinformatics
any guesses of which continent
when i went to school it was seven
continents i don't know how many
continents we have today
uh but howdy rosalind uh so you mean
roslyn franklin
okay who who where was it born which
continent was it born you think
any guesses of where bioinformatics was
actually born
asia okay that would be my guess as well
um x-ray crystallography chromatography
of dna
usa okay probably in europe okay so
we're covering a lot of different
continents here we covered asia europe
europe uh asia is coming up a lot europe
is coming up a lot
um uk yeah
sure okay so cuba okay good guess
actually i'm going to take someone who
just actually
uh maybe one who made the protein atlas
okay we are actually coming really
really close
that is very true so bioinformatics says
actually
i spent a lot of time on the slide just
because it's really fun to see
how people think right where it was born
um
and um yes it was actually i'm going to
get closer to
uh i think it was parimalla um or
someone else said who uh usa right so i
think whoever said usa
it is actually correct so it was
actually born in the u.s
and uh it was actually i'm very proud to
say that it it was actually born in the
universities i work in
georgetown university and i think
you are actually right it was actually
the person who actually made the protein
a class
and who is that person who made the
protein atlas
any guesses so
uh before i introduce um i have to give
tribute to this person robert ledley
he was a faculty at georgetown he
actually died from alzheimer's disease
and he was the person who actually
discovered the whole body ct scanner as
well
and he actually published a paper in
1959
where he said he predicted
that 50 years or 30 40 years from when
he wrote that paper
that we are going to be drowned in data
and we are going to be dealing with
biological data
he is the person who actually hired the
person to georgetown
who actually gave birth to the entire
field of bioinformatics
and she is actually officially now
called
the father and the mother of
bioinformatics she was declared the
father and mother mother of
bioinformatics by
david lippmann who actually was the
director of
ncbi which we will talk about so yes
those of you who said it's a lady yes it
is a lady
and she was the one and she actually
came up with
this atlas of protein sequence and
structures it was actually before my
time as well
in 1965 right so this is so in 1965 i
don't even know how many years ago that
was
um where people used to actually get
sequences published in a book
people used to sequence and send the
sequence to margaret de hoff
and she used to just publish this in a
book
and this book was the one that was
actually posted to all the scientists
around the world
and that is how they used to get the
protein sequences right
so now what were her other seminal
contributions yes
someone said i think it was uh parimla
who said
in atlas and what and she gave birth
at that point she was a visionary she's
considered a missionary because people
are visionaries they already think
what's coming 50 years down the road she
was the one who said well we are going
to have a data explosion
so let's create what is called a
database so she was the person who first
created the prudent database
and if any of you are visiting
washington dc sometime and you visit
georgetown i can take you to
actually the servers and all the books
that she published we still have it
because you know i used to hate history
uh in school but now i love history and
so i have actually kept all her papers
and everything else
as everything was coming along and she
also came up with the single letter code
for amino acids
i'm sure you all know what single
electron amino acid letter code is right
i'm sure
i don't want to busy on that but is
there any reason do you think that she
came up with the single letter amino
acid code for example glycine
gly is gene right alanine
ala is a right so do you know why
yeah efficiency but other than the
efficiency of course it's very efficient
right today we look at it and it's
extremely efficient
but think in 1960s why would she come up
with a single letter amino acid little
code
what do you all think easier
representation yes that is definitely
true but other than that you know you
all are in a generation where we have
gigabytes of data in your phone you're
pairing gigabytes of data in your cell
phone so you can do this whole thing in
a cell phone right
back then yeah it was lack of
computation power
back then they were talking about
kilobytes of data or even
megabytes of data so they did not have
in the super computers
so they wanted to make sure that they
don't have enough space so they have to
actually converted that to
single letter amino acid code in fact i
learned all these stories from people
who work with her
who are actually still a church now
right coding storing information is
efficient that is correct so
now from that where did we head right
1950s
and of course you all know but watson
and creek right without watson click we
won't be here today
and then we have sender sequencing
without sequencer we could not have
sequenced anything
right so insulin was the first protein
and then
of course things started evolving we
started seeing a lot a lot more
excuse me
we started seeing and then we started
seeing polymerase chain reaction
and then
and then we started seeing uh ncbi
and then we started seeing all of these
different databases
and it was in 1991
the official term bioinformatics was
coined and it came up in the literature
excuse me i think i'm screaming a lot
here
with out of excitement uh because of all
of you
right so then we started seeing all of
these tools that was developed and all
of those things and then we started
developing and a lot
a lot of different things started and
you can actually pay attention to here
where the whole genome project
initiative was actually started in the
80s
and then and then the origin of
bioinformatics
the first protein sequence reported was
that of insulin 1956
it consisted of only one 51 amino acids
and then nearly a decade later the first
nucleic acid sequence was reported again
there is a faculty at georgetown who we
who actually passed away two years ago
jack shuriken he was the first person to
actually sequence a trna
when he was at princeton so
thank you so much ojaswee for sharing
the recording with
us so that was dr sona vasudevan
who uh told us about the brief history
of bioinformatics and discussed uh
what by informatics plays a role and how
it does so
and she would be our program mentor
so before i pass it on to uh dr mohair
to discuss this session and details
i would quickly want all of you to
please answer
few of my questions in the poll maybe i
can take the
poll after dr mohit as i
see some technical glitch over here
over to you dr mohit thank you
hello everyone
just a second
and thank you dr sona for that wonderful
talk
and before that ilya
describing genomics and
what i wanted to discuss with all of you
can you see me now
yeah hello everyone it's it's great to
have you all here
and really happy to be in this
session so today as you have
already learned about genomics and
applications of application of genomics
and why bioinformatics and how
bioinformatics started
now i'd like to tell you more about the
program itself
so this is a great opportunity genomics
in the virtual lab
especially for those who are starting
with this field
who are new to this field and especially
as designed for high school students and
beginners
so in this program we will have
different phases
and before i tell you more about the
program
let me tell you a little bit about
myself so my name is
mohit and i am a biomedical data
scientist
so my specializations are in ngs data
analysis
and i am proficient in applying machine
learning
and has a detailed uh like you know
experience of working on structural
biology
and doing molecular dynamic simulations
and doing uh modeling
so um in this program
i'll be one of the cool uh co-project
mentors
along with dr herbert so one of my
research interests and
what what am i doing currently is that
uh about struck that is about the
structure function thing that
elia talked about so currently
uh we are working with a group uh in uh
in ghana and uh in in there we are
working with
uh infectious diseases such as
malaria and coughing 19 which is a very
big issue
especially malaria in in ghana so
uh in in the in the project i have been
we have been able to look into the
mutations that could be
you know that could help design
vaccine strategies so we are using
genomics and
for me i'm using i'm doing some of the
structural analysis
helping connect that how mutations
actually influence
the function of the structure so how
mutations
changes and why these mutations are
important and why some of the mutations
are not
not so important which are to focus upon
and
how we can develop strategies like
vaccine
how we can develop strategies like small
molecules that can actually go and block
uh these uh deadly disease to spread or
to you know
stop uh the severity of these diseases
so before that uh i been
working with several labs and working
with several students
so during my phd time i was i was able
to
um able to teach
a group of students who are doing her
their msc in bioinformatics
and then uh in uh since i joined find
biotech i've been able to
communicate with so many of uh great
minds here
students from high school and scientists
and also people who are doing their
postdoctoral studies a phd
phd projects so it has been really
amazing to be able to work on several of
these important
aspects being a person who has been able
to understand what data is
so to be able to work on sequence data
to be able to work on structural data
we have designed this amazing program
and now i would like to
go next to tell you that how this
program
balances out both uh sequence uh
introduction to bioinformatics and then
take you to the next level of
application of bioinformatics
so in this program we will have
different
stages so there will be week one there
will be week two and there will be week
three and week four
so this is a one month program as you
can see and uh
during this uh entire uh entire one
month journey
we will start with very basics of
introduction to bioinformatics which is
very important and also india talked
about the course
so please look at that so
it will start with a um a
detailed video session by dr sona uh
that would be the first day june um
june uh 21st and then we will have
different aspects of how bioinformatics
is applied and we will go into
you know protein structures we will go
into three dimensional structures from
sequence
uh to understand how these you know
relationships
are there to understand and annotate
things
so in bioinformatics what happens is
that we do a lot of comparison
and we will use multiple sequence
alignment and phylogenetic analysis to
do
such comparisons and understand uh those
relationships
and then as i was telling you that the
exciting part of is to
able to come up with uh the holistic
understanding from sequence level to a
structural level to a to a functional
level and then
uh there will be a guest lecture which
i'm really really excited about
and then we have the second week where
we'll be discussing about uh detail
developing a project in the context of
application of genomics
so in this in the entire program we will
be using
several cloud-based tools and tools that
you can download and apply in your own
systems
as well so there will be a lot of
computational tools that you will be
learning about
a lot you'll be learning about a lot of
algorithms and how they work
and you will be also able to do hands-on
practice on all of them
we have also prepared data sets for you
to take
and also learn and apply this so you we
have already compiled genetic data sets
which have sickle cell anemia cystic
fibrosis and all of those diseases or
also you can work on your own data set
so if you have
been thinking about a disease that you
want to work on if you
if you are have if you have that
interest we can obviously look for data
sets in this entire program
and then we will be able to work on the
project so now i'll just
quickly take you to each of the sessions
that will happen
during this entire course and also then
i'll take you to
uh i'll tell you that what you will
learn from this so
the first session will be about
introduction to bioinformatics as you
can see on the screen
and in this session uh we will be
working on
uh we will be learning about ole miss
technology and get an overview of
databases and resources
that is available to carry out
data-driven research
in sciences uh so in this session we
will learn about the introduction
to bioinformatics and different fields
that are there and
application in the second session that i
was telling you about
that we will be learning about genomic
variants so in this session we will
learn about dna nucleotides and amino
acid variants
as well as how this structural function
structure and function
correlate so what happens in structure
how it affects its function
so think about it it's like that if
something changes
so in the context of a protein
how this works is that from a minoases
or from nucleotides
we come to a level of amino acids that
is through
transcription and translation right and
then we have a protein which
is formed from 20 amino acids so you
have a lot of amino acids
in a chain that forms a protein and then
when you study here in the session you
will be able to what you will be able to
visualize this
that how in a three-dimensional space
the protein look
how how it looks what are the residues
it is you know build off
you can you will be able to look at the
chemistry so you'll be able to look at
the nucleotides that are there you'll be
able to look at
the individual
charges that are there like if the amino
acid is built from carbon nitrogen
oxygen what are the bonding all of that
so you will be able to visualize and
learn from the aspect of protein
structure and function
in the second session so after this
session the third session will be about
sequence alignment
so in this session we will learn about
multiple sequences alignment of both
dna and protein sequences and uh this
will be again the hands on session two
will be about
mutations and in 3d 3d structures
so as i was telling you that these
mutations like the variants you've been
learning about
the variants that have been like
annotated
so often now and being been annotated
and
and are you know categorized as as
variants of concern
so why this is a way why there is uh the
variant of concern because it concerns
because it has such a severity compared
to
the uh the previous version of the virus
right
so a mutations i mean how much they
affect and it's fascinating
that uh simply like the virus mutates
and makes
it self such a devastating i mean
cause such a devastating uh effect so
i i i'm really excited to learn about
what is the mechanism with which it does
that
so how do you know about the mechanism i
mean you can know you know about the
mechanism
when you have the knowledge of how the
sequences
what sequences it has what what changes
it has
you know made to do this and then see
that
in the protein structure i mean what is
actually happening
so why it is uh i mean what has changed
and
if uh if you can compare those two
structures then you will gain a lot more
insights
insights about i mean maybe
how it affects the function and then
because of that
it affects all of that that happens as a
downstream effect right and then we have
the review session so this is the last
session of the week and this will be
um through this these sessions will be
at 10 am um 10 am time
eastern time and uh for our
students and participants in india it
will be at
7 30 p.m indian standard time and for
people from other time zones you could
i mean please you can convert this and
in this session it would be
about the guest guest session and there
will be an interactive activities that
dr sona has planned for all of you
so uh in the guest session we have uh
dr alicia and i've been like really
really excited for this session i was
when i was uh when this was confirmed
that she'd be able to help you and like
uh
give us all a wonderful session
about her journey uh in uniprot so she
is one of those person and in this
program both
dr sona as india told and as you saw
that
dr sona was talking a lot more about uh
the history of bioinformatics
so dr celicia here is also one of those
people who
have been there from the very beginning
as a bio curator
uh biocurator and uh um and managing
the enormous growth of data so it would
be really exciting to hear her
about her journey so that would be the
session uh last session of that week
and after the session we have the uh we
have the weekend activity
as i also already told you that with
every session
we have a lot of online uh courses that
would be
made available to you so you can learn
at your own pace
and you can go through and learn about
some of the technologies
and try to apply that to real research
because that would be one of the
outcomes that we have seen
in the in the program
so um in in this
in this activity uh when you have
learned about visualization tools and
such as pymol
then you will be able to apply this into
a disease or you know finding a
structure
that that has that mutation uh which
makes it more you know dangerous or
which makes it
to identify those sort of projects and
then we will be using primol
so in this weekend you uh we will you
will have that
assignment to prepare a few slides about
uh
and find the structure and find uh and
use pymol and all of that
so the second week is about research as
i was telling you it would be
uh uh it would be from our team
uh at omixlogic and in this session
uh we will start with in this week we
will start from literature review
and project design here we will learn
about uh the review of
uh what you have learned uh in the
previous session and we will learn about
virology
and we will learn about how you can ask
about questions like
how big data research what what big data
research project is
what is the research question that
you're trying to ask and
uh how you can generate that research
question so as i was
discussing before that uh this this is
to design a research project
to be able to work on a research project
and to come up with you know
presentations and come up with
uh come up with uh posters
or maybe come up with a publication
when you have finished the analysis
which would be a very later phase of
of this entire journey so this session
will be dedicated to those
uh who who would want to work on project
and then we will learn about these uh
viral species here we will learn about
how genomics is applied
in virology followed by this we will
learn about how you know how
metagenomics is a technique is such a
powerful technique
that you should all should all be aware
of
you should all should learn about that
how uh
you know how to apply and understand
metagenomics
that can study i mean directly these
samples without culturing in the lab
very powerful technique and has been
widely used in many of these
natural and many of these
difficult times in this pandemic so
followed by this once we have the
understanding of
genomics and its application
metagenomics and
its application we will learn about the
vaccine antibiotic and antiviral drugs
and its strategy here we will learn
about um
about the basic principles behind
antiviral
and antibacterial drug as i was telling
you that from structure
how you can understand and design
these molecules design these bigger
molecules or smaller molecules
that could help us actually find uh
solutions right so uh followed by this
uh we will have the hands-on session in
the samsung session
we will go to ncbi and we will take uh
the entire genomes and do the analysis
through the ty info platform
and in this entire course you will be
also using the tbi for platform
which is a very powerful and
comprehensive tool cloud platform
which is an amazing place to
do your projects online so yeah so in
this session we will be using all of
that resources
and towards this end of the week we will
be helping you
and uh work on your project and come up
with these project presentations
that could be reviewed by the judge in
our
symposium in august
so um to tell you more about uh the full
program registration
and how you can join the store maybe
right before you jump into that could we
launch the poll and just kind of
uh learn a little bit more about the
participants
that's okay
okay so um uh mohit say
yeah you go ahead sonic
yes india so uh there is some uh problem
at my end i'll get
uh to you regarding this dr mohit can uh
take this session no the poll is on uh
the poll is live yes people can see it
and their answer
so i'll just guide you everyone through
the questions that we have
the first question about your education
so high school undergraduate or
bachelor's
graduate or master's postgraduate or phd
or
postdoc student researcher or faculty
high school teacher or lecturer or other
so i see that the majority here are
undergraduate right now
we'll just give it a little more time
the second question is about your
research
interest so what are you most interested
in
uh we chose topics that are somewhat
general general
and broad so genomics bioinformatics
data science the future of medicine or
introduction to omics in general
different types of omics data
so if you could respond that question
number two
i see about 50 of you have voted now so
please
go on and the final one is where are you
from
so which country are you from united
states
india africa united kingdom
sri lanka bangladesh nepal russia
turkey or iraq so
this was uh based on some of the
submissions that we already had and so
that's why
this was inserted so abukari if you
could answer in the poll
um that would be helpful
okay and uh i think we'll leave the poll
on for some time and
maybe you could continue and speak a
little bit about the registration
yeah thank you everyone for uh
answering the questions on the poll
and uh if you have any more questions
that are not there uh could you please
unmute yourself and ask me also i mean
if you want to ask
if you have any questions regarding the
program and the sessions and what we
would cover
please you can ask me also by unmuting
yourself
about the full program registration uh
so as you have already
gone to the learn platform and have uh
learn
uh portal and have created a login
i think uh next
next i will i will ask uh snarlika to
take you to the
uh to the program page and show you the
registration details
so sunalika would you be able to do that
or should thank you
so much thank you so much
so i hope you all have already signed up
on our uh portal if you have not then
you can do
so right away i'll wait for two minutes
for you all to please sign up
i'm sharing the link with you all so
once you are signed up on the
omixlogic portal
i'll just log in so that you can see how
you have to sign up
you need to add your email id create a
password for yourself and sign
in and you can also link your social
and sign up as well so let me do through
my social account
so that you get to know how it would be
done
you can now sign in yourself on the
portal
with me and please tell me if you have
done so
with a yes or one maybe on the chat box
so once you're signed in on the portal
you need to go to the programs
and here you will get the list of all
our programs which are ongoing and the
upcoming ones as well
so here you will get the program
genomics in the virtual
lab and as you can see here that you
would
get all the information for the program
on the program page
you would get to know about the program
so this is one of the
project videos of our students from the
genomics in the virtual lab 2020 this uh
the program which was conducted last
year
and we had amazing outputs so i'll be
shortly taking you through the blog as
well and i'll tell you where you can
find more details about the
projects that were conducted by our
previous year students
and on the program page you'll have the
details of each and every session
as well the dates would be marked on the
calendar here
the topics that would be covered in each
and every session
and this program page is also to be used
for your registration
so those who want to register themselves
for the
program they can simply go to the
program page
and register themselves as well now how
would they do so i'll just quickly take
you through it
this is the program page and you need to
start your application
and i would be sharing the details with
you of how you would
take your application ahead the moment
we receive your registration with
us and i had few of the queries
regarding certification
so yes after the completion of the
program you would be getting the
certificate and this completion would be
awarded
once you finish all your assignments for
the program and the tasks given by you
by the lender
and i just told you that we have all
these session details as well on the
program
page and each and every topic that would
be covered so once we
cover the session once the session is
over we would be uploading the video
of the session now this is just an
example program page
so we have the program ongoing machine
learning for biomedical drug discovery
we are done with the
three sessions we have the third one
today and the two of them the video has
been uploaded
here so we have in the webinar also the
people who have already enrolled
themselves for the program
so this is for your knowledge as well
that you will get the link to the
program page you need to bookmark it
and keep it with you throughout the
program and you would be able to
go to the program page and look for the
video if you missed out anything
and you you can refer to the video
anytime and do your assignments as well
and also you would have the zoom session
links for the upcoming uh
sessions and you can simply log in to
the session whenever the date of the
session is scheduled for
and now let me take you
through few of the more resources that
you would
get the access to along with the program
so by being a part of the program
first of all you would also have the
access to all the courses
on our portal and also you would
definitely have the access to to the t
by info server now this is a very
powerful server now why do i call it
powerful it says that because we have
uh different sorts of utilities over
here
which have got integrated pre-built
libraries which could be used to carry
out
different sorts of tasks and analyze
your data sets and we would get into
more detail of it in the program itself
and to get more details on the program
about what all would be covered who is
the speaker and
uh you can just go to our blog page
now this is the block for the
program which has all the details of the
program
and talking about nist chair nestor is
our collaborator
from sri lanka and
then we have the session details here as
well on the pro
blog which you could try for any time
and as
dr mohit has already discussed all these
sessions
they are mentioned on the blog as well
i would also request you all to please
follow us on social so that you stay
updated with all our
upcoming programs and also all the
opportunities that we have
and also we keep on posting a lot many
opportunities in the field of
bioinformatics about internships about
recruitments and a lot many more things
as well
so being a part of this group on
linkedin would definitely help you so
i've shared the link with you
you can uh join the
join our group and also we are there on
facebook by the name buying biotech and
again i'm sharing a link with you all
join us there as well so that we stay
connected and you don't
miss out on any of the opportunity and
the program that we would be
having and
before i finish sharing my screen
i would want to take the question
so and it asks okay thank you
if i could interrupt you just for one
second yes
so let's go through the poll results
just to kind of share with all of you
what that looks like it looks like we
have the majority or undergraduate
students
and the second largest category is
graduate masters
so the reason i am starting with this
question is because
we do have a number of additional
programs
that are targeted to the more advanced
students
including a research fellowship where
we're just exclusively focused on
helping you complete your research using
bioinformatics tools
and there we have a number of mentors
that you can interact with
that are working using bioinformatics in
a variety of different
research fields so on the same program
you will find
the on this page you can see in the top
menu there is a
link to research so sunanika if you
could show the research page
so if you are a graduate student or an
undergraduate student
or a postgraduate student or even a
researcher that would
like to work on a research project
we have this three or six months
research fellowship
program you could check that out now
let's go to the next
uh what is your research interest so
a lot of you here are interested in
genomics and as we already mentioned
genomics has
many different applications and uh
sonolique if you could now go to
the home page on the home page
we have the four categories
of different types of projects that we
have
uh yes the home page
okay so if you scroll down we have here
there we go oncology infectious diseases
neuroscience and agriculture so
what you will find on this portal are
not just
lessons and tutorials but also project
examples
the project examples are sourced from
the public domain so they're from
journals
please go back selenica just stay on the
four
sections please so um in each one of
these categories we have
project examples from peer-reviewed
journals
we take the data follow the same
analysis
approaches that are described provide
some insight into alternative
methods of analysis and also
open it up for your independent project
on the same topic
and so now sonata if you could go down
below and show
how some of the research fellows that
we've had in the past
have been able to use this training to
design a project of their own
so we have a whole page dedicated to
this
and you can see here a few of the
examples so if you would like to work on
an independent research project
the genomics in the virtual lab program
is a great place to start
and as you get started you will see how
we have a whole
structure for you to follow from a basic
research question
to identifying the data set to then
being able to work on an independent
project
okay and then finally uh we did ask
about
what country you're from uh so we have
here
uh india is the largest
the second one was from africa and then
the third one
is from the united states so
from india i did want to mention that we
have
a number of campus ambassadors
that you can connect with if you have
an interest in finding out a little bit
more about how this works
learning about the research fellowship
program if you have any questions so we
have a whole set of
undergraduate and graduate students in
our research fellowship
and so we invite you to connect with
them and the way to connect with them
and maybe even hear from their
experience
is to email uh sonalika or join
our uh social media group on linkedin
and on facebook
and letting us know uh that you would
like to talk to someone
uh so uh we will be sharing with you
some details
and yes you can email marketing at
pine.bio
if you have any other questions thank
you
okay and uh so we um
will uh i saw that there's a question so
i think maybe you can just show
if you log out from your learn account
and show the program page without being
logged in
and just walk us through the
registration pricing
and what are the different options thank
you
and by the time my page is loading i
just wanted to tell that we are also
there on telegram and whatsapp so we
have groups
for telegram and whatsapp as well so
that we have direct direct communication
with you all
and i would be sharing the links of our
groups as well and you you can be a part
of our groups and ask us anything
anytime and we would be there to help
you out with that
so for the registration process here on
the program page itself you go to the
same link and then you
need to start your application here is
the link
you need to start your application and
you would be directed towards the
different sorts of level we have for
this program
so we have the bigness level the
intermediate and the advanced level and
uh the difference is just because of the
different sorts of provisions that would
be given throughout the
program so the beginner one has got the
provisions mentioned and intermediate
one has got one on
one mental support as a additional
benefit
as uh being part of the intermediate
level for the program
and the advanced level would have some
more options
as in to get extra time to work on a
project
and then the option is there for
certificate for completion that
that is though for every uh level that
you would be in
but there is an also an option for
certificate of excellence as you would
be getting some more time to work on a
project
of your own right and uh to talk about
the further details so let's say
any one of you chooses the intermediate
level let's say you just need to
sign in and then check out so the moment
you check out you would be directed
towards the payment
page and once you're directed towards
the payment page you need to add the
coupon code that i shared with all of
you over the mail ids
and sorry and if you didn't get one then
you can let me know and i
will share with you once again sorry my
system has
got yes it's working now
yeah so that's it i hope your uh doubt
is cleared anik so
anybody else if you have any doubt you
can ask
i am till then sharing the lengths of
our so kias the price is not affordable
for us
africans in eucupia so
uh kia we would be sending can you
please drop me a mail at
marketing at the refine dot bio so that
we can discuss
about the different sorts of
opportunities
anushka says can you please share the
code yes
uh sure anushka can you please do the
same as
i asked kiara to do so please mail me
and i would be able to revert you back
just within
a few minutes and i am sharing the link
of our telegram group
so be a part of our group we have a
channel and also group by a name of
psyomex
that's a bioinformatics community where
we have
students by informatics background
and different fields as well and there
we have
free live sessions every week and we
discuss
different sorts of topics
like we had uh one session
yesterday where we discussed about
astrobiology
and our research fellows were there
subrajeet and
who shared about astrobiology and how it
could
change the whole way the way we look at
science and it was really interesting
so if you guys are not following us on
youtube
you can do that right away i'll share
the link
of a youtube channel as well because we
keep on uploading videos for each of our
session there and also we are live right
now by the way
and being a part of a youtube community
you would definitely be able
to uh look at all the webinars and
sessions if you miss out any one of them
uh then and uh yes you could be
benefited in that way so this is our
youtube channel it's link
uh okay dr pankaj asks the feedback link
for participation certificate sorry dr
pankaj
feedback link as in a feedback link for
the program
for the certification feedback link i
didn't get sorry
uh could you please specify what you are
saying
abukhari has a question he says working
with
yes sir you can let me answer that one
please yes so abukari
um we have um some tools that you can
use with amplicon sequencing
for uh plasmodium falciparum
and maybe what i would suggest
depending on your level of
bioinformatics your
you know previous bioinformatics let me
ask you maybe a few questions so that we
can understand
do you already have experience using
bioinformatics tools for genomic data
analysis
abukari
you can also unmute yourself i think
let me actually find you so i can help
that
um so uh
the tools that we have
okay yes and and i think sunday for you
it's saying that the whatsapp group is
already full so you can't join that
okay so um i've asked to unmute you if
you can
okay can you hear me yes we can hear you
good so i started with
fine bio infectious disease
and we just completed the core psd
i also did that with transcriptomics i'm
doing there with
a few courses to finish and this is how
far
i have started with find value i hope to
register this particular course and my
interest in time i will basically stand
with the fact that
i wanted to help me impact
positively in my upcoming project
that we're going to do ample
conditioning
okay so because you've already done a
lot of the training
and you probably have a theoretical
understanding of what are the steps that
you need to do
to get you to now apply these skills
that you've acquired
to a practical project i would recommend
joining the research fellowship so the
research fellowship program
is intended to help people like yourself
that have completed the training
go through identifying the type of data
which you have
the amplicon sequencing the application
would be to plasmodium
and then potentially thinking about what
kinds of questions would you like to
study would you like to address with
your project potentially you're looking
for
vaccine efficacy or maybe you're looking
for
drug resistance or maybe you have some
other questions maybe genetic
variation in nigeria let's say or
something like that
and so a lot of these topics are best
when you do literature review you can
refine your question
understand where you should focus your
efforts then
once you've got the data you would do
the exploratory data analysis and
understand the variation
and then ultimately once you are done
preparing that project and sharing it
with the rest of the research fellows so
we actually have a whole group
focused on plasmodium we have a group in
ghana
out of the naguchi memorial institute
for
biomedical research and also we have a
group in africa and nigeria
where they have a few people joined in
the research fellowship
and they have this common interest in
malaria so
maybe that would be the best next step
for
your situation avocado i'm very grateful
thank you all right yes thank you for
the question
as well so um if anyone else has any
question
uh please go ahead i think i've made it
possible for anyone to unmute themselves
so if you have a question please do let
us know you can also unmute yourself and
speak and i think the
question about the feedback link and the
certification
so we don't provide a webinar
certification
these are really webinars to facilitate
discussion
and introduce some of the upcoming
opportunities
we have quite a number of free webinars
that you can join throughout the month
some of them are related to our research
fellows presenting their research
projects
some of them are to discuss important
topics like the psionics club
some of them are to introduce some of
the upcoming training opportunities so
please
take a look at either the social media
groups
or the youtube channel where we share
some of those sessions with everyone
but because we're sharing it publicly we
don't really
provide a certificate with those
so that's just to answer that question
okay gerald is asking what are the
bioinformatics tools that the program
requires the learners to use
so dr vasudevan comes from a structural
biology background so she will be
talking about tools like pymol
but she also has a lot of experience
with genomics so probably sequence
alignment so clustal
blast and things like that as sonalika
already mentioned
you will have access to the tby info
platform
so let me just briefly share with you
some of the tools that are available
all of you that have registered on the
learn portal
will have access to a demo pipeline
already for free
so you can go ahead and explore this
platform and see what kind of tools are
available here so
thank you so much for sharing that link
so as you can tell
there are many different tools available
and they're organized in such a way that
you can build fairly complex pipelines
without
minimal background in bioinformatics
there are some examples you can take a
look here at some of the examples in
transcriptomics
or here you can see some examples for
other tools like
phylogenetic tree of uh different types
of
methods that we have included so really
this is
many different tools for multiple
sequence alignment for mapping of the
raw reads to the reference genome of
building phylogenetic trees
there are tools for processing data and
analyzing it with different types of
unsupervised and supervised methods of
analysis
so those are the tools that are going to
be covered in the program
but what you should probably know coming
into the program
are some of the basics about sequences
what they look like as well as what
kinds of
questions could you ask now let me share
just one more thing
on the learn portal let me just go to
the home page again
under coursework a lot of the tools that
you've seen
on the talber portal are actually
scripts
in r and python and so one of the things
that you will be able to do
is take some of these and learn about
how they are
implemented so if you go to the courses
you can take a look at introduction to
genomics which is a good place to start
but also
you can see uh getting started with
bioinformatics in python and getting
started with bioinformatics in r
so here you will find some scripts that
you can run directly in the browser and
understand how to
analyze sequences and visualize data
okay so what is the role of
bioinformatics in discovery of new
coveted vaccines
well so it's obvious that vaccines
are going to have to continue and
improve
as we see new variants of concern and
as we see other viruses coming out
and becoming potentially pandemic
so i think there is definitely a huge
need for new vaccines and vaccine
improvements now as we think about the
vaccine
function and how they are designed you
will understand the
relationship between sequence and
structure and then
immune response and in that process
bioinformatics plays a huge role because
we need to understand what variants to
focus on
what impact do those variants have on
immunogenicity
how do they interact with the different
receptors and so
that's where the vaccine design field i
think is going to go because
the process of going from a known
sequence and structure to
being able to produce those proteins or
rna
really is i think something that was
proven to be very effective in this
pandemic
gerald is asking is the program geared
towards structural biology and
biophysical methods in the context of
bioinformatics no
it's going to combine genomics with
structural biology so how do you do
sequence alignment
how do you understand the relationship
between sequence and phenotype
and then how can you map this on the
structure
to understand the relationship between
the two
okay
okay thank you so um i don't see any
more questions so hopefully we were able
to answer all of those
thank you so much elia and the last
thing i wanted to share with all of you
is that we also have a lot of programs
which would be
starting by the end of june and also
the first week and middle of july so
though
so we had a question regarding saskov2
so we have this uh program coming up
which would start from 9th of july and
you can just go to the program page and
get the details of it and if this
interests you
maybe you can be a part of it and learn
more about how we can uh
use bio and by informatics effectively
to do research in this particular domain
and then we have bioinformatics for
infectious diseases program as well
that would be starting on uh on
22nd of uh june and
last but not the least we have the
genomics in the virtual lab
about which we are here to discuss about
and the program would be starting on
june 21st and the last
day to register for the program is june
20th we would be closing the
registrations
at the end of june 20th so you all are
requested to register
if so for the program and yes that's it
so thank you everyone for joining
today's webinar
and if you have any doubts and if any of
your questions went unanswered or you
could not
ask me you can anytime nail us at
marketing either a pine dot bio
and move it either a fine dot bio and me
and dr mohit would be there to help you
out at any step
india dr pankaj has a question regarding
clinical trials or vaccine whether it is
helpful
can you please take that
i i would just maybe suggest uh we we
ask a few questions so dr
pankaj kumar um maybe we could schedule
even a conversation it sounds like maybe
you're involved in related research so
we'd love to learn a little bit more
about it
you're welcome to email me elia at
pine.bio
and i'd love to set up a chat to learn
more about your interest
thank you india and dr deepak we would
definitely look forward to have a
conversation with you
and gerald uh you can't login into
cloud service like that so you need to
first sign up in the omics logic
and then you need to be a part of our
program
uh any of the programs that we have it
could be the
the program for which we are here today
or the research fellowship program
or the programs that would be coming up
and then you would get the access to the
t
buy info server we would be giving you
the access
for that and if you want the access to
the server
to carry out your research work only and
then you can reach out to me for that
i'll send you all the details how you
could get that
and then you can maybe use the server
with the credentials
and do your research i hope that answers
your question
animeka says you want to develop your
project on neuroscience what options i
have so i
animaka we are already working on a lot
of new neuroscience projects in our
research leadership program
i uh received your message over linkedin
as well i'll send you the details
of the program and i'll also send you
the
project examples for new neuroscience
you can go through them and get an idea
of how the research fellows
our ex research fellows worked on it and
then we can proceed further yes
thank you so much everyone for uh being
here for the webinar
it was really really great to know you
all and
we look forward to your participation in
the program
and also meeting you on uh different
sorts of other webinars
and stay connected with us over social
so that we
keep our meeting again and you don't
miss any of the
update on the upcoming programs ah
sonata i have one question
yes please right yes
yeah well i try to click on the you know
you showed up for a different real
project on home page
yeah when i try to click the lawnmower i
could not do that
yeah do i need to do anything or
if you're not able to do that then let
me share with you the blog of the
research fellowship
program and you can maybe i could just
uh one second clarify yeah so that is a
blog post that you should take a look at
but if you go into the courses tab
uh you'll see that you can search there
um what is available so um
let me just show right here
so if you go to the courses tab
yes right here you can search for a
specific project if it's available
and so we have a few examples or if you
would like to develop an independent
project in one of these
areas again take a look at some of the
examples that sonalika shared in the
blog
those are examples of projects that
students have completed
in the research fellowship so if you
would like to develop something like
that you can go to
research and that tells you a lot of the
information that you need to know
of how this works and some of the
examples down here as well
yes i'd like to um develop independent
project yeah
so before that
for an independent project maybe we
could also schedule a time to speak
uh learn a little bit more about your
background your interests
what exactly you're interested in um so
if you could email sonolique and myself
and we could schedule a time to meet
with you okay
okay that would be great
all right thank you so much sudba
i hope that helps you and thank you so
much everyone for being a part of the
webinar
uh let's meet the next time thank you so
much bye bye take care
bye